PROFESSOR: We got here
finally in terms of position
and in terms of momentum.
So this was not an accident that
it worked for position and wave
number.
It works with position
and for momentum.
And remember, this phi of
p now has interpretation
of the weight that is associated
with a plane wave of momentum
p, and you're summing
over P in here.
So we'll do the natural
thing that we did with x.
We'll interpret
phi of p squared--
dp is the probability.
Find the particle with momentum
in the range p, p plus dp.
Just the same way as we would
say that psi squared of x, dx
is the probability to find
the particle between x and x
plus dx.
So this is allowed now by the
conservation of probability
and this, therefore,
makes sense.
It's a postulate, though.
It's not something
that can derive.
I can just argue that
it's consistent to think
in that way, and that's
the way we finally
promote this phi of p,
which did encode psi of x.
Phi of b has the
same information
as phi of x. phi of p is the
weight of the superposition
but, finally, it's given a
probabilistic interpretation.
It represents a probability
to find the particle
with some momentum.
So this is what is going to
allow us to do expectation
values in a minute.
But I want to close
off this discussion
by writing for you the
three-dimensional versions
of these equations.
3D version of Fourier transform.
So this is what we
want to rewrite.
So what would it be?
It's psi of the vector x.
Since you're going to
have three integrals--
because you're going into
it over three components
of momentum-- this factor
appears three times.
So actually, it's 2 pi h bar
to the three halfs integral phi
of vector p into the i vector
p dot product vector x h
bar d cube p, and phi of p
vector the inverse theorem--
same factor, we keep the nice
symmetry between x and p--
psi of x vector negative
exponent same dot product
but negative exponent d cube x.
So these are the three
dimensional versions
of your x versus p.
And there is a three-dimensional
version of Parseval.
So oh there's a three
dimensional version
of the delta function.
Just like we had a
delta function here--
a delta function in
three dimensional space
would be delta cubed
x minus x prime would
be one over 2 pi cubed
integral d cube k e to the i k
vector x minus x prime vector.
It's all quite analogous.
I think you should appreciate
that you don't have to memorize
them or anything like that.
They won't be in
any formula sheet,
but they are very
analogous expressions.
Parseval also works
in the same way.
And you have-- just
as you would imagine--
that the integral all over
three dimensional space of psi
of x squared is equal to
the integral over three
dimensional momentum
space of phi of p squared.
So the three results--
the Fourier theorem the
delta function and Parseval
hold equally well.